[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today we're
going to Courtney who's joining us in
Raleigh North Carolina Courtney how can
we
help hey uh thank you for taking my call
you bet um so we just um completed a
very significant home repair uh very
unexpected for about
$270,000 oh my gosh hold the phone what
did it burn down and you built
it um we were actually victims of fraud
um oh no there was significant water
damage termite damage um a lot of a lot
of issues that were hidden oh so they
sold you a house that was just a
disaster and you didn't know it is that
what I'm
hearing yes oh my gosh but 270 Grand did
you just got this thing down to the
studs and start
over basically yes oh bless your heart
oh my gosh and you have no recourse
here uh we actually do um we are
pursuing that path um but we are of the
mindset that we are in control of our
destiny and so um we want to you know
consider any levers that we can pull to
accelerate getting out of this mess um
we were lucky to be able to cash flow
about
$150,000 of it um but we had to take out
some um some loans a 401k loan and a
home equity loan um to just get through
it so my question is um should we sell
the house and be able to accelerate um
This Mess by um probably a year year and
a half so what is your total Consumer
Debt put the the home equity loan aside
the 41k loan aside what you have any
other Consumer
Debt we do so we did stupid and went to
um buy two cars before all of this
before knowing anything about the house
so um we have uh student loan for n
Grand and then two cars for 45 Grand so
a total of about 54 in Consumer Debt in
addition to the 401K loan and the home
equity okay and what is remaining on the
401K loan the home equity
loan uh 12,000 on the 401K loan and
97,000 on the hok is that on top of your
mortgage yes oh dear lord okay what's
left on the
mortgage uh
350,000 and what's your household
income um it's about 200,000 okay good
we've got a good shovel to work with
here but goodness gracious we've got a
pile of debt so what could this house
sell for now that you fixed it up I
imagine you did not Roi in the least bit
on
this we did not um we weren't even
considering selling it at that time but
we um met with our Realtor and he thinks
we can get 600 for
it okay so you sell for 600 you get rid
of the 401K loan the home equity loan
the mortgage you you'd get rid of all of
your debt completely and still have a
little bit left over to start with
correct yeah okay I mean here's the
thing I selling a home is a last ditch
effort for me but this feels like one of
those situations where I go you guys
aren't going to be able toing at night
and I imagine the emotional turmoil
you've experienced just rebuilding this
place it's kind of given you the
ick it is especially my husband I think
there's more the mathematics make sense
behind it I think we're just dealing
with the emotional side of should we
sell it and just move on I mean does he
resent the house because I resent this
house and I've only known about it for
four
minutes he very much resents okay then I
I almost always agree with George and
that's G to well as head I disagree that
this is last ditch in this situation I
think this is option A I would sell the
house oh okay I see what you're saying
okay Clean Slate yeah it's been a
massive pain in their rear it's just
nightmarish as you say to try to dig out
of this they can but why not just get
free and clear of it all and if you got
a rent for a year you got an income
where you can get up a nice down payment
you go into it fresh and you go we
learned a lot and this is one of those
sometimes you win sometimes you learn
and they don't lose if they sell and
they get out and they're so much more
educated but they're free of all of this
uh I don't the hardest part is going to
be freeing yourselves of the guilt the
shame the stupid tax the sunk CA fallacy
yeah all of that is going to be the
hardest part the numbers we can deal
with you guys have a great income you
can clear your debt and still walk away
with probably what 50 Grand
M I would do it tonight I have a sign in
the yard like within five minutes of
this phone call if it were me uh this is
a no-brainer is that where you all were
leaning before you
called uh yes because the home can no
longer give us what we want we bought it
before having kids and now we have a
daughter and the location just isn't you
know there there's not a lot of younger
families in our area so um now there's
extra reason this is one of many reasons
Courtney for the benefit of the audience
can you explain how this fraud happened
did you not get an inspection how did
you get swindled
here we did have an inspection it was a
result of flippers um coming in and
flipping the property they had done some
work on it um but we later found out
that they did not do honest work on it
and really tried to spend as little as
possible to just make sure it didn't um
it didn't you know fall down before the
sale um so but the inspector CAU nothing
the inspector was like this house is in
tiptop shape go for it yes the inspector
needs to be sued at this point that's
insane have you gotten back in touch
with the inspector and said here's what
we had to
do we have yes what did they have to say
about
it they've pretty much thrown their
hands in the air and said that they're
not liable
is it stuff that they couldn't see in
the general inspection meaning behind
drywall so you discovered it only when
you started doing some
Renovations yeah pulling back the siding
and realizing what was underneath it
okay uh not to defend the the inspector
but Stacy and I had this happen in the
home we're in now George you've been
there that front room we were putting
shelves in and and so we saw some mold
on the drywall underneath some trim and
so not anything can be seen like that so
again not trying to defend the inspector
but sometimes that can happen there was
a leak rainwater was getting in a small
crevice in an area of brick up against
the house anyway the point is that can
happen I'm so sorry Courtney but uh Hey
listen I'm glad they that they that they
can get out of it so thanks for the call